I want to make sure that every single
person who is in this country who's
aspiring to become part of the American
fabric understands that nothing this
president says should be taken apart we
are Americans as much as every one else
this is our country and we are where we
belong and I told people on my election
night in the great state of Minnesota we
don't just welcome refugees we send them
to represent us in Washington and as
much as he's spewing his fascist
ideology on stage telling you as
citizens to go back because they don't
agree with his detrimental policies for
our country we tell people that here in
the United States descent is patriotic
here in the United States this agreement
is welcomed debate is welcomed and
especially in the people's house all of
our voices are uplifted and heard and we
see her we see me we see her we see
everyone in this country and they are
not only
neighbors my friends my sisters and
brothers they are also my constituents
and they're my fellow citizens and this
American president this president does
not speak for them
and we are going to make sure that we
get a president that they could be proud
of